ASSISTANCE AND COOPERATION WITH
THE INVESTIGATIONS REMAINS THE
SAME TODAY."
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS,
THANK YOU.
U.S. AND ITS ALLIES ARE GANGING
UP ON RUSSIA OVER THE POISONING
OF A FORMER SPY.
THE KREMLIN IS PROMISING
RETALIATION TONIGHT.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT AMY KELLOGG IS
ONCE AGAIN IN MOSCOW.
>> THE U.K. AND ITS ALLIES, THE
U.S., GERMANY AND FRANCE,
PRESENTED A UNITED FRONT,
STATEMENT OF SOLIDARITY, SAYING
THEY ALL AGREE WITH BRITAIN'S
ASSESSMENT THAT RUSSIA WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ATTACK ON A
RUSSIAN DOUBLE AGENT AND HIS
DAUGHTER.
IT SAID IN PART "THIS USE OF A
MILITARY GRADE NERVE AGENT OF A
TYPE DEVELOPED BY RUSSIA
CONSTITUTES THE FIRST OFFENSIVE
USE OF A NERVE AGENT IN EUROPE
SINCE THE SECOND WORLD WAR,"
ADDING "IT'S AN ASSAULT ON U.K.
SOVEREIGNTY AND BREACH OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW."
THE DAY AFTER ANNOUNCING
PUNITIVE MEASURES AGAINST
RUSSIA, BRITISH PRIME MINISTER
THERESA MAY VISITED SAULSBERRY
WHERE SERGEI SKRIPAL AND HIS
DAUGHTER WERE MYSTERIOUSLY
POISONED MARCH 4.
RUSSIA SAYING IT WILL EXPEL
BRITISH DIPLOMATS IN RESPONSE TO
THE REMOVAL OF THE DIPLOMATS.
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS SAY THEY
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER, WEAKENED
BY TROUBLES NEGOTIATING BREXIT
IS SIMPLY TRYING TO BUILD
STRENGTH BY LASHING OUT AT
RUSSIA.
>> Translator: WE ARE READY TO
RETURN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
EUROPEAN UNION WHEN OUR EUROPEAN
NEIGHBORS LOSE INTEREST IN
FOLLOWING AMERICAN-RUSSIAN
PHOBIC TENDENCIES.
>> THIS IS ATROCIOUS AND
OUTRAGEOUS WHAT RUSSIA DID.
WE HAVE RESPONDED.
FRANKLY, RUSSIA SHOULD GO AWAY.
IT SHOULD SHUT UP.
>> HIS COMMENTS MAY FUEL THE
RUSSIANS ARGUMENT THAT BRITAIN
IS PROVOKING THEM.
BRET, THE RUSSIAN MINISTRY OF
DEFENSE FELT COMPELLED TO ANSWER
THE COMMENT TONIGHT, ISSUING A
STATEMENT DECRYING THE BRITISH
DEFENSE SECRETARY, THE COARSE
LANGUAGE, SOMETHING THEY SAID
PERFECTLY CHARACTERIZES HIS
"INTELLECTUAL IMPOTENCE."
NO ONE HERE EXPECTS THIS
FURTHERING SENSE OF SIEGE IN
RUSSIA IS GOING TO HAVE ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON